ظاهرة الكلاب البشرية
لا تنسى الإعجاب بالفيديو و
الاشتراك في القناة وتفعيل الجرس ليصلك كل جديد
اجتاحت العالم الغربي ظاهرة غريبة لدى مجموعة
من الناس يلبسون كالكلاب ويأكلون أكل الكلاب
ويشربون مثلها كذلك لأغراض مادية أو جنسية.
أطباء علم النفس يقولون إن هؤلاء مصابون
باضطرابات نفسية وشخصية
ينجم عنها احتقار الذات وتعذيب النفس المازوخية
تحول البشر إلى كلاب.
لم تعد ظاهرة نادرة الحدوث قد انتشرت في
أوروبا وأمريكا وكندا واستراليا،
ففي بريطانيا وحدها يوجد عشرة آلاف متحول، وهو رقم مخيف
بالنظر لمجتمع متطور.
يقول أحد المتحولين في تصريح لمجلة الجارديان
البريطانية تعيش الكلاب حياة مريحة بشكل لايصدق،
ليس عليهم أن يذهبوا إلى العمل أو
يتألموا بسبب أنواع المشاكل الإنسانية.
ليس لديهم حتى إحساس بالمستقبل.
أنا محظوظ إذا تمكنت من تجاوز بضع ساعات دون
أكون مستيقظا من بعض القلق الكامن،
ولا أحد يفرك بطني عند الطلب
في هذه الصورة تظهر شابة تدعى جينا فيليبس تبلغ
من العمر واحدا وعشرين عاما، كان لديها وظيفة جيدة
فقد كانت تعمل في مختبر طبي، لكنها تركت
عملها وقررت أن تعمل ككلب بشري،
أو بالأحرى قررت التحول إلى كلب بشري
اكلت وشربت ومشت
ونامت كالكلاب، كل هذه الأعمال لم تذهب سدى
لدى الفتاة التي تقطن ولاية تكساس، فقد
أصبح دخلها يعادل مئة ألف دولار شهريا،
وتحقق ملايين المشاهدات والمتابعات على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فقط لمتابعة فديوهاتها
وهي تعيش كالكلاب.
لم يعد الأمر سرا ولم تعود هذه طقوس خاصة
بالعالم السفلي، وأصبح العالم غريبا
ولا نعرف عنه الكثير. هذه الظاهرة التي تزداد في تسارع
تدر على من يطبقونها قرابة السبعين ألف دولار شهريا.
إذا أردت أن تصبح غنيا ما عليك إلا أن
تصبح كلبا
وأنتم متابعينا هل هذا المبلغ الكبير من الدخل الشهري قد يجعلك تفكر
أن تعيش حياة الكلاب أو بالأحرى أن تتحول إلى كلب
هو سؤال لكم من طاقم قناة شاهد لتعرف
الجواب منكم أرجو وضعه في تعليق؟؟